wenn sie Benito Mussolini zuhören der
ein oder zwei Dinge über Faschismus
wusste er sagte der Faschismus sei die
Verschmelzung von staatlicher und
unternehmerischer macht jetzt werden die
Leute das bestreiten und sagen dass das
nicht genau das ist was er gesagt hat
aber wenn man sich wirklich damit
beschäftigt ist es
das Milch ist ein wichtiger Bestandteil
guten Ernährung verwenden Sie die beste
Milchqualität die ihnen zur Verfügung
steht durch den Genuss von
unhygienischer Rohmilch können
Krankheiten übertragen
[Musik]
werden
im Jahr 2010 gab es zeitgleiche Razzien
an zwei Orten in
Kalifornien schwer bewaffnete Beamte
stürmten Privatgrundstücke und
verhafteten mehrere US-Bürger wegen des
Handelns mit einer verbotenen Substanz
drogenrazien gibt es in den USA recht
häufig das ist nur eine der Methoden mit
denen die Behörden uns von bösartigen
Substanzen fernhalten nur war dies keine
drogenraier die Substanz die verkauft
wurde war kein Crack kein Crystal mess
und nicht einmal illegaler
Schnaps es war
Milch das ist ein Beispiel dafür wie
riguros die Regierung vorgeht um
missliebige Parteien
auszuschalten in diesem beruft sich die
Regierung auf das Argument des
öffentlichen Interesses dass Rohmilch
von Natur aus unsicher ist sie sei ein
Nährboden für Bakterien und da sie nicht
pasturisiert sei so das Argument Berge
sie ein enorm erhöhtes Risiko für die
Verbraucher soass sie nicht erhältlich
sein sollte das ist der Standpunkt der
Lebensmittelbehörde FDA und die
Regierung geht gegen dieses eine Segment
mit brutaler Gewalt vor indem sie
praktisch Sturmtruppen schickt und die
gesamte Milchfabrik stilllegt und die
gesamte Milch beschlagnaht unabhängig
davon ob sie kontaminiert ist oder
nicht die FDA hat eine Razia auf diesem
Biomarkt durchgeführt um uns vor den
Gefahren zu schützen die von nicht
pasterisierter Milch
ausgehen sie haben kein Problem damit
dass man Rohmilch trinkt wenn man z.B
auf dem heinweg eine streunende Kuh
findet und beschließt sie selbst zu
melken aber ein seriöser Landwirt der
versucht sie an willige Kunden zu
verkaufen das geht gar nicht obwohl es
sich bei diesem Biomarkt um einen Club
handelte in dem jedes Mitglied eine
Verzichtserklärung unterschrieben hat in
der das potenzielle Risiko des
rohmilchkonsums anerkannt wird war das
für die FDA nicht ausreichend ist diesen
Leuten nicht klar dass Rohmilch ein
einstiegslebensmittel ist was kommt als
nächstes Menschen die Käse essen Ruhe
aus oder Gott bewahre Eier zum Glück war
die FDA zur Stelle und rettete diese
Erwachsenen mit vorgehaltener Waffe vor
den Gefahren der
Rohmilch der Grund warum pasturisierte
Milch nicht unter diese Kontrolle fällt
und der Grund warum Rohmilch im
Gegensatz zu Käse Eiern rohen Austern
und Sushi nicht unter dieselbe Kontrolle
der FDA fät ist dass die großen
milchhersteller eine wichtige Lobby
innerhalb der FDA s sie haben sehr
kleine Gewinnspannen pro Einheit und
wenn in Biomärkten und anderen
Geschäften viele Verbraucher
Rohmilchprodukte kaufen hat das
erhebliche Auswirkungen auf die großen
Milchverarbeiter die rtien in
Kalifornien waren kein Einzelfall in den
letzten Jahren gab es überall in den USA
razieren um gegen den Verkauf vieler
Bioprodukte
vorzugehen doch trotz aller Behauptungen
über Sicherheitsbedenken oder Risiken
ist eines
klar die Maßnahmen der Aufsichtsbehörden
und damit auch der Politiker die sie
leiten sind nicht durch irgendeine
Vorstellung vom öffentlichen Wohl
motiviert sie sind motiviert durch den
Wunsch an der Macht zu bleiben und dafür
braucht man
Geld das Problem des politischen Systems
in den USA ist dass sich alles um Geld
dreht und das führt sofort zu dieser
Dichotomie zwischen denen die es sich
leisten können im System mitzuspielen
und denen die es nicht können um für ein
Amt zu kandidieren braucht man
eineinhalb Millionen Dollar um für den
Senat zu kandidieren braucht man etwa 11
Millionen Dollar wenn man also kein Geld
hat wohin geht man dann man wendet sich
an die Leute die die Hand ausstrecken
und Geld bereialten um den Wahlkampf zu
finanzieren aber sie werden eine
Gegenleistung verlangen denn natürlich
geben sie das Geld nicht aus wohltätigen
Gründen es ist ganz klar ein Vorteil für
große Unternehmen weil sie mehr
Ressourcen haben um Einfluss zu
kaufen politische Einflussnahme wird zu
einem weiteren Arsenal im Marketing
Werkzeugkasten großer Unternehmen aber
anstatt sich selbst zu fördern nutzen
Sie diesen Einfluss um die Konkurrenz zu
unterdrücken und der Schlüssel zu allem
sind
Lobbyisten
die Menschen glauben dass wir in einer
freien Marktgesellschaft leben aber das
stimmt nicht die Regierung und die
großen Unternehmen sind heute viel zu
eng miteinander verbunden vor allem in
den Vereinigten Staaten und das ist im
Wesentlichen auf die Lobbyarbeit
zurückzuführen wir haben
Vetternwirtschaft wir haben keinen
Kapitalismus in den
USA vor allem wenn es um das Militär
geht und die große Medizin die großen
Lebensmittelkonzerne wie Monsanto und so
weiter die meisten Menschen wollen das
nicht aber trotzdem wird es uns
aufgezwungen weil Monsanto durch die
Lobbyarbeit der Lebensmittelindustrie so
viel Einfluss im Kongress
hat was also ist Lobbying nun ganz
einfach Lobbying ist die Beeinflussung
von Entscheidungen die von Gesetzgebern
und Behörden getroffen werden sie wissen
schon die Leute die die Regeln machen
und die Leute die diesen Einfluss
ausüben nennt man Lobbyisten gut
vernetzte Fachleute mit schicken Anzügen
und flotten Sprüchen Lobbyisten sind in
der Regel Experten in ihren Bereichen
sie beraten die Gesetzgeber wie Sie
sicherstellen können dass die Amerikaner
den größtmöglichen Nutzen aus den
Gesetzen ziehen während sie gleichzeitig
möglichen Schaden begrenzen das ist eine
gute Idee warum sollte man einen
Expertenrat nicht wollen und genau hier
wird es brenzlich manchmal beschließen
die Gesetzgeber dass der Job auf der
anderen Seite besser ist und werden
selbst Lobbyisten sie verlassen die
Regierung und gehen zu einem privaten
Unternehmen wobei sie ihre Verbindungen
und ihren Einfluss mitnehmen dieses
Phänomen wird als Drehtür bezeichnet die
Leute wechseln von der Regulierung einer
Branche zur Arbeit in derselben Branche
und manchmal auch mehrmals hin und her
Unternehmen lieben es so mächtige Leute
auf ihrer Gehaltsliste zu haben und tun
alles um sie anzulocken und die
Regulierungsbehörden helfen ihrerseits
indem sie ein paar Gesetze erlassen die
ihren künftigen Arbeitgebern zugute
kommen und mit dem Drehen der Tür kommt
eine Vielzahl neuer Gesetze die einigen
Unternehmen zugute kommen und andere
behindern aber das Geschäft läuft weiter
und am Ende wird niemand wirklich
verletzt außer natürlich den
Menschen sie werden Kongressabgeordnete
sehen die sich für ein bestimmtes
Sonderinteresse einsetzen und nach ihrem
Ausscheiden für dieses Sonderinteresse
arbeiten und das gleiche gilt für alle
Regierungsbehörden in der Tat ist das
die normale Art Geschäfte in Washington
zu
machen
Regierung und große Unternehmen sind im
Grunde genommen dasselbe was ist der
Unterschied zwischen einem Unternehmen
und einer Regierungsbehörde wenn das
Unternehmen die Politiker mit
Wahlkampfspenden kauft und die Politiker
tun was ihnen gesagt wird indem sie
Gesetze verabschieden die das
Unternehmen verabschiedet hätte wenn das
Unternehmen die Regierung
wäre traurigerweise ist dieses Phänomen
heute nur allzu gebräuchlich und es ist
nicht spezifisch nur für eine Branche
sondern es scheint dass viele der
Behörden die die Macht haben unser
tägliches Leben zu beeinflussen durch
die Drehtür korrumpiert
[Musik]
werden wenn man Ausschüssen
Regierungsbeamten und Behörden die Macht
überträgt die Wirtschaft zu regulieren
führt das immer zu Korruption es ist zu
verlockend für die Leute diese Macht
nicht für ihre eigenen persönlichen
Ziele zu nutzen und die Drehtür ist nur
Beweis dafür dass es immer immer zu
Korruption führt wenn man der Regierung
und ihren Behörden die Macht gibt den
Handel zu
regulieren ne aller Bundesgesetze sind
nicht das Produkt derer die wir wählen
sondern das Produkt der nicht gewählten
Leiter dieser bürokratischen Behörden
wir haben in den USA also keine föderale
Republik die in ihren Grenzen agiert was
wir haben ist eine unbegrenzte
bürokratische Oligarchie in der diese
bürokratischen Agenturen weitgehend ohne
jegliche Rechenschaftspflicht
arbeiten das ist keine repräsentative
Regierungsform sie vertreten nur die
mächtigsten und die Leute die ihnen das
meiste Geld geben die Konzerne die
multinationalen Unternehmen haben die
Macht übernommen sei es in der
Landwirtschaft sei es im Rundfunk der
Pharmazie oder im Einzelhandel
egal in welchem Bereich einige wenige
kontrollieren
alles Gesetze und Vorschriften sind für
jede moderne Gesellschaft unerlässlich
es gibt einige Aktivitäten die zum Wohle
des Gemeinwohls kontrolliert oder
verhindert werden müssen auf welcher
Seite der Straße man fahren darf ob ein
fünfjähriger eine Flasche Jack kaufen
oder wie oft man in einer einzigen
Sitzung zum buüffet gehen
darf
okay vielleicht streichen Sie jetzt den
letzten Punkt aber sie verstehen was ich
meine aber durch die vielen Absprachen
zwischen den Regulierungsbehörden und
der Industrie die sie regulieren werden
die Gesetze die unser tägliches Leben
Regeln übertrieben unnötig und oft
gerade zu
unsinnig die Sicherheit und Freiheit der
Bürger ist für einige unserer
Gesetzgeber nicht mehr das vorrangige
Ziel es gibt nur wenig buierung tut das
nicht von der Entscheidung beeinflusst
ist ein bestimmtes Interesse zu
bevorzugen viele Vorschriften werden
unter dem Deckmantel des öffentlichen
Interesses erlassen aber darunter sind
Sie das Produkt von Verhandlungen
zwischen Branchenführern und der
Regierung um eine zugangsbarriere zu
schaffen und viele dieser Maßnahmen
haben enorme wirtschaftliche Folgen da
sie sowohl die Konkurrenz für ein
Unternehmen ausschalten als Stellung
verbessern diese Beziehung zwischen
großen Unternehmen und
Regierungsbehörden wirkt sich nicht nur
auf ihre Konkurrenz in der Wirtschaft
aus sondern auch auf unser
allertägliches
Leben in einer Volkswirtschaft möchte
man die Produkte und Dienstleistungen
produzieren die am stärksten nachgefragt
werden und niemand außer dem Markt weiß
das aber wenntiker auf den Plan treten
und ihr eigenes Urteilsvermögen an die
Stelle des Marktes setzen versuchen Sie
nicht einmal den Markt zu überlisten und
herauszu findinden was das Beste für uns
ist sie versuchen in der Regel nur einem
bestimmten Individuum oder einer Gruppe
einen Vorteil zu verschaffen und zwar
auf Kosten einer anderen und so gibt es
klare Gewinner und Verlierer denjenigen
der eine Subvention erhält im Gegensatz
zu demjenigen der reguliert oder
besteuert wird aber unabhängig von den
individuellen Gewinnern und Verlierern
verlieren wir alle zusammen weil
Wohlstand vernichtet wird und die
Ressourcen nicht optimal verteilt
werden wenn man genug Geld hat kann man
dafür sorgen dass man in jeder
Angelegenheit die einem am Herzen liegt
gewinnt vielleicht geht es darum die
Gesetzgebung zu stoppen vielleicht darum
etwas durchzusetzen aber letztlich geht
es darum die Politik zu gestalten und
diese Politik hat echte Auswirkungen auf
unser tägliches Leben sie bestimmt
welche Art von Produkten wir im Laden
kaufen Ken sie bestimmt wie sicher diese
Produkte sind sie bestimmt was wir über
diese Produkte wissen
dürfen der Krieg der FDA gegen Rohmilch
ist nur ein Beispiel dafür wie die
großen Lebensmittelhersteller ihre
Verbindungen in Washington nutzen um
unsere Auswahl im Lebensmittelgeschäft
einzuschränken und gleichzeitig ihre
eigenen Gewinne zu steigern aber es ist
bei Leibe nicht das einzige
Beispiel
die Regierung hat sich mit der
Landwirtschaft verbündet es gab nie
wissenschaftliche Studien die belegen
dass gentechnisch veränderte
Lebensmittel mit konventionell
angebauten gleichwertig
sind die Lebensmittelbehörde der
Vereinigten Staaten sagte nun monsanto
hat sich für die Sicherheit der
Lebensmittel verbirgt und Monsanto sagte
die Behörde hat bestätigt dass sie
sicher sind
Bus und dasment
zusammen aber einige kleine unabhängige
Bauernhöfe entscheiden sich dafür keine
patentierten Genpflanzen zu verwenden
oder für große Agrarkonzerne zu arbeiten
einige wollen einfach nur ihre Region
mit nahhaften frischen Lebensmitteln
versorgen ein solcher Landwirt ist Joel
[Musik]
salatin er betreibt seinen Hof mit einer
inovativen neen Technik die er
Weidehaltung nennt es hört sich verrückt
an aber vielleicht hat er ja
recht wir haben ganz andere Produktions
und
verarbeitungskriterien erstens bewegen
sich unsere Tiere sie sind nicht in
großen engen Tierfabriken untergebracht
unsere Tiere werden nicht mit Drogen
behandelt wir impfen nicht geben keine
Medikamente aber wir bewirtschaften
unseren Hof in einem geschlossenen
Kohlenstoffkreislauf Anst Dünger zu
kaufen die Lokalisierung der
Kohlenstoffkreislauf die Bewegung der
Tiere das Fehlen von
Medikamenten all das ist 180° anders als
das heutige industrielle globale auf
Erdöl basierende
lebensmittelsystem es gibt also einen
gesunden Markt für traditionell
gezüchtetes Fleisch und Produkte aber
warum existieren nur so wenige
unabhängige Bauernhöfe im ganzen
Land
die Geschichte von Chicago und seinen
großen viehöfen symbolisiert die
wirtschaftliche Revolution die im Gange
war auf den Farmen produzierten
Maschinen und verbesserte
landwirtschaftliche Technik eine Fülle
von Lebensmitteln für das in und Ausland
die neue Welt der Massenproduktion
erforderte eine zunehmende Konzentration
von Kapital durch die Bündelung der
Investitionen vieler Menschen wurde die
Aktiengesellschaft zum Vorbild für die
Gründung riesiger neuer Unternehmen
durch die Globalisierung und
korporatisierung von allem wird es für
unabhängige Landwirte für unabhängige
Menschen im lebensmittelsystem immer
schwieriger ihre Produkte an ihre
Nachbarn Freunde an die Familie oder was
auch immer zu
vermarkten und man denkt jeden Tag
darüber nach welcher Bürokrat heute in
mein Leben eindringen
wird
jedes Mal wenn die Regierung in den
Markt eindringt begünstigt sie die
größten Akteure weil die in der Lage
sind sich Gefälligkeiten zu erkaufen um
in einem regulatorischen Klima
Vergünstigungen zu
erhalten ich weiß dass viele
Verbraucherschützer es gut meinen wenn
sie sagen wir brauchen mehr Aufsicht wir
brauchen mehr Vorschriften für diese
schlimme Sache die hier passiert
ist
was sie nicht wissen ist dass die
Regulierung wenn sie dann tatsächlich in
Kraft tritt und bis auf die Ebene der
landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe vordringt
immer immer immer den kleinen Erzeugern
schadet und den großen Erzeugern
hilft das ist die Drehtür essen sie
nicht gesund essen sie nur
Mist ein paar Unternehmen kontrollieren
alles es gibt nur eine kleine Gruppe von
agrarkonzernen die die gesamte
Lebensmittelproduktion
kontrollieren sie verdrängen alle
anderen aus dem Geschäft sie wollen
keine
Konkurrenz der Kleinbauer ist immer eine
Bedrohung wenn 50 Millionen Menschen in
den USA von sich aus entscheiden dass
sie ihre Produkte lieber bei Kleinbauern
oder auf Bauernmärkten kaufen weil sie
sie für gesünder halten dann ist das
eine Abkehr vom System die Regierung
will das nicht und Monsanto will das
ganz sicher auch nicht und auch keiner
der großen Agrarkonzerne will das es ist
also besser alles zu tun um den
Kleinbauern in Amerika auszulöschen man
lässt ihn bankrott gehen zwingt ihn sein
Land zu verkaufen das dann von einem
größeren Agrarunternehmen übernommen
wird bis schließlich die gesamte
Nahrungskette von großen Konzernen und
der Regierung kontrolliert
wird die Vorschrift die kleinen
unabhängigen Farmern wie der von Joel
stin auferlegt werden haben eine Hürde
geschaffen die die Größe und den Umfang
seines Betriebes einschränkt und ob
diese Vorschriften nun gut gemeint sind
oder nur auferlegt wurden um den großen
einen unfairen Vorteil zu verschaffen
das Endergebnis ist dass viele Produkte
die Joel gerne verkaufen würde als
illegal eingestuft
wurden die Dinge die wir gerne tun
würden vom Pökeln von Fleis zum Verkauf
von Rohmilch Z würden gerne Rohmilch
verkaufen und wir haben Kunden die gerne
Rohmilch bekommen würden aber es ist
illegal wir hatten gerade einen
Inspektor des Gesundheitsamtes hier der
uns sagte dass unser geflügelschlachthof
illegal sei und er uns schließen will
sie waren der Meinung dass es von Natur
aus unhygienisch ist wenn der Stall zur
Luft hin offen
[Musik]
ist dasin ist ein Lager unter
erbärmlichen Bedingungen und mit
Verbotsschildern fast mit allem
durchkommt aber weil wir extrem
transparent sind draußen wissen Sie hier
draußen macht uns das anfällig für den
Anthropomorphismus ignoranter
Menschen sie denken wahrscheinlich dass
diese landwirtschaftlichen Verordnungen
für sie bedeutungslos sind wenn diese
Verordnungen ihre Wahlmöglichkeiten
einschränken wie kommt es dann dass sie
in jedem Gang des supermarktesz V
verschiedenen Marken und hunderte von
verschiedenen Lebensmitteln finden
können ich meine wie viel Auswahl
brauchen wir
denn der Durchschnittsmensch geht in den
Supermarkt und er sieht all dieses Zeug
in den Regalen und er denkt sich was
soll das heißen ich habe keine Auswahl
ich kann C chocular Frühstücksflocken
fruit Loops Cracker Jacks was auch immer
bekommen ich kann Kartoffelchips von Z
verschiedenen Firmen bekommen was soll
das heißen ich habe keine Auswahl es ist
also schwer zu verkaufen weil es den
Leuten schwerfäll zu verstehen was sie
nicht bekommen
können was sie nicht bekommen können ist
Rohmilch was man nicht bekommen kann ist
Geflügel das im Hinterhof geschlachtet
wurde und nicht durch eine große
Verarbeitungsanlage gelaufen ist es gibt
eine enorme Menge an handwerklich
hergestellten Lebensmitteln die jetzt
nicht mehr erhältlich sind weil sie
kriminalisiert und verboten
wurden
um das Risiko manche Dinge wie Rohmilch
sind einfach zu riskant um sie an die
Öffentlichkeit zu
bringen schließlich könnte verunreinigte
Rohmilch theoretisch so schädlich sein
wie
[Musik]
Gift echtes Gift hingegen ist offenbar
in
[Musik]
Ordnung wen man über risik sprechen
nicht Richtung die uns Insektizide
beschert hat den Rinderwahnsinn das
Klonen die
Gentechnik das sind alles sehr riskante
Dinge ich meine ob man nun daran glaubt
oder nicht man muss sich darüber im
Klaren sein dass das alles sehr
risikoreiche Dinge
sind und das sind dann diejenigen die
sagen ich setze mein Vertrauen in Dich
was meine Nahrung
betrifft ich glaube dass die Menschen
ständig riskantes Verhalten an den Tag
legen wenn sie ihren Kindern
pastürisierte Milch cocopuffs C chocula
Müsli oder fruit Loops geben ist das
riskantes Verhalten aber die Regierung
hat entschieden dass das kein riskantes
Verhalten ist riskant ist es ein Glas
Rohmilch zu
trinken wenn man es genau nimmt ist es
gar nicht so schlimm keine Rohmilch zu
bekommen ich meine wer braucht schon
Rohmilch wenn man frittierte Mozzarella
Sticks oder leckere hähnchenfinger
bekommen kann
Essen ist schließlich essen
oder man muss sich mal bewusst machen
dass 1979 als die erste
Ernährungspyramide vom Agrarministerium
herauskam mit Getreide ganz unten dass
das der Beginn der Adipositas und
Diabetes Epidemie war weil die
Kohlenhydrate ganz unten waren es ist
eine Tatsache dass Amerika heute viel
viel gesünder wäre wenn die Regierung
uns nicht gesagt hätte was wir essen
sollen
vielleicht haben sie es mit den
gesättigten Fetten und dem Käse im mitat
etwas übertrieben wen kümmert das wir
haben Zugang zu den besten Medikamenten
der Welt egal ob Sie einen Ruhepuls von
116 haben ob sie nach dem dritten
Cheeseburger schwitzen wie ein Schwein
oder ob ihnen von all den Medikamenten
schlecht wird die Sie einnehmen es gibt
Mittel die Ihnen
helfen und wir sind uns alle einig einen
Bereich gibt in dem wir strenge
Vorschriften brauchen
Arzneimittel schließlich will niemand
dass unsichere Medikamente an die
Öffentlichkeit
gelangen es gibt natürlich viele
Medikamente die hilfreich sind aber was
mich beunruhigt ist dass gegen eine
bedeutende Minderheit von Medikamenten
die von der Arzneimittelbehörde
zugelassen wurden die eigenen
medizinischen Prüfer Einwände hatten aus
Sicherheitsgründen viele unsichere
Medikamente sind auf dem Markt
zugelassen worden die tatsächlich zum
Tod führen zu Leberversagen
Nierenversagen
Herzinfarkten diese Medikamente sind auf
dem Markt viele von ihnen immer noch und
werden jedes Jahr neu
zugelassen wir verdanken es den strengen
Qualitätskontrollen der
Arzneimittelbehörde dass ein Medikament
wie viox das über 100.000 Herzinfarkte
und ztausende von Todesfällen verursacht
hat schnell vom Markt genommen wurde
nach nur 5
Jahren und 2,5 Milliarden Dollar Gewinn
für den Farm riesen
merk wenn ein Behördenmitarbeiter
wissentlich ein unsicheres Medikament
wie wox genehmigt und es auf dem Markt
belässt obwohl es 140.000 Herzinfarkte
und 60.000 Todesfälle gibt und trotzdem
dieses Unternehmen merk verteidigt dann
stimmt hier etwas nicht da läuft
irgendetwas furchtbar falsch warum kann
diese Person nicht zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden sie kommen damit durch
sie kommen nicht nur ungestraft davon
sondern im Fall des Mitarbeiters der das
getan hat Lester Crawford wird er
schließlich von einer Firma namens
policy directions angestellt in einer
sehr hohen Position und diese Firma
vertritt
[Musik]
merk
vielleicht war der wo Vorfall nur ein
einmaliges Ereignis es gibt viele
hilfreiche Medikamente auf dem Markt und
die Behörde sollte nicht wegen eines
kleinen Ausrutschers unter die Lupe
genommen werden ich meine es ist ja
nicht so regelmäßig
vorkommt die Behörde sagt dass alle
Medikamente die es in Amerika gibt
sicher und wirksam
sind so kommen Sie in die Arztpraxen und
Apotheken und deshalb nehmen die
Menschen sie
ein nun 106000 Menschen werden jedes
Jahr in den USA durch von der Behörde
zugelassene Medikamente getötet die
Behörde räumt das auf Ihrer eigenen
Website ein sagt nichts darüber dass sie
die Verantwortung dafür übernimmt für
sie ist das nur eine weitere
medizinische
Tatsache über 100.000 Todesfälle durch
verschreibungspflichtige Medikamente
jedes Jahr man sollte meinen dass die
Behörde bei all den strengen Tests die
sie durchführt bevor Sie ein Medikament
auf den Markt bringt einige dieser
lebensbedrohlichen Nebenwirkungen
entdecken
würde das sind die Flaschen die
schließlich ihren Weg in die Arztpraxen
und Kliniken im ganzen Land finden
werden noch während sie das Ende der
Produktionslinie erreichen laufen
weitere Tests und werden Proben an die
Regierung
geschickt das Protokoll des Herstellers
wird überprüft und dann einer ganzen
Reihe von komplexen wissenschaftlichen
Tests
unterzogen das gesamte System der
Arzneimittelprüfung durch die Behörde
ist ein Schwindel es ist darauf
ausgelegt die Interessen der
Arzneimittelindustrie zu schützen viele
Menschen sind sich dessen nicht bewusst
aber die Behörde testet die von ihr
zugelassenen Medikamente nie sie führt
überhaupt keine unabhängigen Tests durch
sie verlässt sich ganz auf die Tests die
von den Befürwortern des Arzneimittels
durchgeführt werden also von denjenigen
die den Antrag auf Zulassung gestellt
haben die ein Eigeninteresse haben sie
werden für alle arzneimitteltests
herangezogen sie führen ihre eigenen
Tests
durch die Behörde führt also keine
unabhängigen Tests für die von ihr
zugelassenen Medikamente durch aber kann
man es ihnen verübeln dass sie bei so
vielen neuen Medikamenten die Tests an
die Hersteller
auslagern denn wenn man einer
milliardens schweren Pharmakonzern nicht
trauen kann wem
dann es hat mehrere Fälle von Korruption
in diesem Prozess gegeben in denen
negative Informationen von der Behörde
ferngehalten wurden damit Sie ein
Medikament zulässt so hat sich S
eventtis bei seinem Medikament ktech
hauptsächlich auf eine klinische Studie
gestützt von der die medizinischen
Gutachter der Behörde die den Fall unter
die Lupe nahmen herausfanden dass sie
gar nicht stattgefunden hatte sie haben
sie
erfunden es gab Ermittlungen des FBI und
strafrechtliche Verfolgung aber was hat
die Behörde getan die medizinischen
Gutachter sagten meine Güte sie haben
sich bei diesem Antrag auf einen Betrug
verlassen wir sollten ihn
ablehnen aber die behördenkommission
genehmigte ihn sie brachte ktec auf den
Markt sie sehen also es ist dieser Grad
an Einfluss und Korruption der es
unmöglich macht das amerikanische Volk
zu
[Musik]
schützen angesichts der Tatsache dass
Medikamente von der Behörde trotz der
einwendee ihrer eigenen Gutachter
zugelassen werden kann es kaum einen
Zweifel daran geben dass die Drehtür in
der pharmazeutischen Industrie lebendig
und gesund ist und für den Fall dass sie
doch noch einen winzigen Funken Zweifel
haben denken Sie an den Fall
bilen sie sollten vielleicht ein paar
Tabletten gegen Übelkeit berei
halten der Kongressabgeordnete Billy tin
der dem Energie und handelsausschuss
Vorstand sollte dafür sorgen dass ein
Absatz in das Gesetz aufgenommen wird
der die gesamte Regierung daran hindert
den Stückpreis für Medikamente herunter
zu handeln die im Rahmen von Medicare
Part D erworben werden
müssen
mit anderen Worten sie sind gezwungen
den Preis zu zahlen den die
Pharmaindustrie pro Einheit für die im
Rahmen von Medicare Party gekauften
Medikamente festlegt das könnte die
Pharmaindustrie in die Lage versetzen
die Nation nach Belieben finanziell in
die Knie zu zwingen und so kam es dass
dieser Absatz in der buschregierung in
das Gesetz aufgenommen wurde in die
Regierung verließ seinen Posten im
Kongress aufgab Chef des us pharmbands
wurde und das höchste Gehalt erhielt das
bis dahin jemals gezahlt worden war 2,5
Millionen Dollar pro Jahr als Belohnung
für seinen Ausverkauf der Nation zum
Schutz der
Pharmaindustrie auch wenn die Regierung
die Lebensmittel und Medikamente die sie
für sicher hält oft schlecht auswählt so
versucht sie zumindest nicht uns etwas
davon
aufzuzwingen außer vielleicht bei
george lamber ist Abgeordneter des
Repräsentantenhauses von New Hampshire
und einer der führenden Befürworter von
Impfungen in seinem
Bundesstaat als ich uns
Repräsentantenhaus kam fragte mich
jemand ob ich an einem Gesetzentwurf zur
freiwilligen Impfung arbeiten würde dann
fand ich heraus dass man bei einer
Epidemie alle Menschen zu einer Impfung
zwingen
kann USA wird zurzeit darüber gestritten
ob man eine Impfpflicht einführen kann
da jeder Bundesstaat seine eigenen
Ausnahmeregelungen hat die Eltern in
Anspruch nehmen können aber jetzt wird
versucht zu sagen wir werden euch
zwingen euch impfen zu lassen ob ihr
wollt oder nicht ihr habt nicht die
Freiheit zu
entscheiden wenn wir über medizinische
Sicherheit und Freiheit sprechen sollte
jeder die Wahl haben welche Verfahren er
möchte man kann eine medizinis Ausnahme
bekommen man kann eine religiöse
Ausnahme bekommen aber keine aus
Gewissensgründen vor ein paar Jahren
hatten wir in new hampcher ein Problem
mit Spritzen die möglicherweise mit
Meningitis verunreinigt waren aber wenn
man geimpft oder gespritzt werden muss
woher weiß man dann dass die Spritze
nicht verunreinigt
ist wenn Sie wollen dass ihre Kinder zur
Schule gehen oder an anderen Aktivitäten
teilnehmen sagt die Regierung dass sie
das tun müssen oder ausgeschlossen
werden das ist ein Problem denn wenn man
in den Nachrichten hört dass es etwas
gibt D das Leben gefährdet sollte man in
der Lage sein eine fundierte
Entscheidung zu
treffen das ist es worauf Freiheit
letztendlich hinausläuft die Freiheit zu
entscheiden wie man leben möchte ob zum
Guten oder zum Schlechten und diese
Freiheit sollte nicht von der Regierung
außer Kraft gesetzt werden außer in den
extremsten Fällen oder um uns vor
teuflischen Bedrohungen zu
schützen weed Grass Ganja joint du
chonic Ace Lobo loco loveboat Buddha
blun Pot PIN Chiba Chiba 420 und hashib
kurz Hasch
egal wie man es nennt egal mit welchen
hippen Straßennamen man es bezeichnet es
kommt alles aus demselben
Versteck es ist alles
Marihuana Marihuana es ist eine der
gefährlichsten Drogen die die Menschheit
kennt und für fast so viele Todesfälle
pro Jahr verantwortlich wie Asteroiden
oder Haiangriffe es kann bei ansonsten
gesunden Erwachsenen zu Lachkrämpfen und
Hunger
führen zum Glück führen die tapferen
Männer und Frauen zahlreicher Behörden
seit Jahrzehnten einen unermüdlichen und
teuren Krieg gegen diese gefährliche
Pflanze der Krieg gegen Drogen ist ein
Krieg gegen die Menschen es ist ein
Krieg der für die Pharmaindustrie
geführt wird damit sie
verkaufen kann ich meine Herr Gott von
wie vielen Leuten habe ich
Horrorgeschichten gehört dass sich ihre
Kinder mitin zrönen oh das ist doch
Quatsch wie wär es mit ein bisschen
oxyodon um Dich glücklich zu machen hast
du Schmerzen damit gehen sie weg aber
wer nicht Heiman kein Gras das wird dich
umbringen du hast R Madness
[Musik]
gesehen ist ein berühmter für die
usreierung produzierter Film der be
vingenommene Herangehensweise an das
Thema
Marihuana von dem er behauptet es sei
schlimmer als Heroin und der
Generationen vor den Gefahren von
marijuana bewahrt schon ein einziger Zug
Mary Jane kann dich dazu bringen wie ein
Narr zu tanzen unkontrolliert zu
lachen oder deine Freunde gewaltsam zu
ermorden wie
peinlich normal ist eine gemeinnützige
Organisation Ziel die Legalisierung von
Cannabis in den gesamten USA
ist jedes Jahr werden in den Vereinigten
Staaten 800.000 Menschen wegen marijuana
verhaftet 90% davon nur wegen Besitzes
über einen Zeitraum von 40 Jahren sind
also etwa 27 Millionen Menschen wegen
marijuana verhaftet worden soass ein
riesiges Universum von Menschen
entstanden ist die effektiv von der
Regierung verarscht worden
sind
als wir die Drogenbehörde verklagten
entschied der Richter 1988 in seinem
endgültigen Urteil dass marijuana die
sicherste therapeutische Substanz ist
die dem Menschen bekannt
ist das ist eine ziemlich starke Anklage
gegen alle anderen
Drogen die Gerichte haben also anerkannt
dass marijuana die sicherste
therapeutische Substanz ist die dem
Menschen bekannt ist aber seit den 30er
Jahren war Marihuana Gegenstand
zahlloser schwerwiegender und
irreführender
Propaganda langfristiger Konsum von
Marihuana kann zu einer psychischen
Abhängigkeit führen du wirst alles
Mögliche versuchen um an deinen Stoff zu
kommen die Leute fangen an dich mit
Namen wie potad oder smoky mcbong water
zu beschimpfen da du jegliche Motivation
verlierst brichst du wahrscheinlich die
Schule ab entwickelst eine Vorliebe für
Sitar Music und wirst vielleicht soar
von ein oder zwei Polizisten
angefasst mit marijuana machen die US
Regierung und ihre Stellvertreter auf
staatlicher Ebene seit mindestens 75
Jahren Propaganda es gibt 1200 Annoncen
der partnership drugf America und 85 bis
90% dieser Annoncen waren gegen
marijuana und allein der Name drugf
America verdient nichts anderes als
reines
Gelächter
Amerika dies ist die drogensüchtigste
Gesellschaft in der Geschichte der
Menschheit und der Verband für ein
drogenfreies Amerika wurde ursprünglich
von den Alkohol Tabak und
Pharmakonzernen gegründet deren
Geschäftsmodell soweit ich weiß der
Vertrieb von Drogen
ist abgesehen von den persönlichen
Gefühlen gegenüber Marihuana lässt sich
die Tatsache nicht leugnen dass die
Kriminalisierung dieser Substanz kaum
mit anderen Substanzen im gleichen
Bereich wie Alkohol oder Tabak
vergleichbar ist aber wer profitiert von
den Millionen die für die Verhinderung
des Konsums und die strafrechtliche
Verfolgung der Konsumenten ausgegeben
werden es gibt Einrichtungen die sich
stark für die Beibehaltung des Status
quo einsetzen die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden die
Regierungsbehörden die aus der
Prohibition hervorgegangen sind wie die
partnership drugf America das
drogenpräventionsprogramm die
Drogenbehörde
sie werden immer gegen die Legalisierung
sein die dritte Gruppe sind die Alkohol
Tabak und Pharmakonzerne sozusagen der
lachende Dritte sie versuchen Dinge wie
die Partnerschaft für ein drogenfreies
Amerika ins Leben zu rufen aber sie
wollen ganz sicher kein drogenfreies
Amerika die vierte Gruppe sind
Unternehmen die mit der Prohibition Geld
verdienen also private Gefängnisse und
Drogentest Unternehmen das ist
wahrscheinlich die offensichtlichste
Opposition denn wenn man mit Marihuana
erwischt wird kann man entweder den Weg
der Strafverfolgung und einer möglichen
Verurteilung wählen und dann ins
Gefängnis gehen oder man geht in den
Entzug selbst der Direktor von normal
sagte wenn ich mit einer kleinen Menge
marijuana erwischt werden würde würde
ich mich für den Entzug entscheiden wenn
ich die Wahl hätte und so werden Ihnen
80% der Klientel von der Regierung
praktisch auf dem Silbertablet
serviert sich um eine incestuöse
Beziehung zwischen den Profiteuren der
drogenrehabilitation und der Regierung
die die Klienten direkt bis zur Tür
bringt und wir die Steuerzahler zahlen
für die
Rehabilitation in der Sprache die die
Süchtigen untereinander verwenden sagen
sie nie lass uns eine marijuana
Zigarette rauchen sie sagen let turn on
oder
BL wie das Trinken von Rohm auch das
Rauchen einer Marihuana Zigarette
offensichtliche
Gesundheitsrisiken aber ob Sie nun einen
Joint rauchen oder einen im Freien
geschlachtetes Huhn von Ihrem örtlichen
Bauern kaufen wollen mächtige
Lobbygruppen haben sich mit den Behörden
abgesprochen um ihre
Entscheidungsfreiheit
einzuschränken wenn die Regierung ihnen
gewaltsam die Tür Eintritt und mit
gezogenen Waffen auf ihr Grundstück
kommt um sie dazu zu bringen ein
bestimmtes Verhalten einzustellen D niem
sonst schadet ist das eine soziale
Ungerechtigkeit ich betrachte es im
Moment fast ausschließlich als eine
Diskussion über persönliche Freiheit und
darüber wie sehr sich die Regierung in
dein Leben einmischen darf und zwar
gewaltsam und mit gezogenen
Pistolen okay wir haben viel über Essen
und Medizin und
Lobo gesprochen aber genug von diesem
hippy Gerede jeder weiß dass sich die
Welt nur um eine Sache dreht und zwar um
Milch ich meine
Geld aber ähnlich wie unabhängige
Landwirte sind auch kleine Unternehmen
im Finanzsektor mit strengen
Vorschriften konfrontiert von denen die
großen Akteure
profitieren
ich bin in der wertpapierbranche tätig
und es gibt alle möglichen Vorschriften
an die ich mich halten muss die meisten
davon schützen meine Kunden die
einzelnen Anleger nicht aber das ist
nicht der Grund warum ich glaube dass es
sie gibt es ist die Ausrede die die
Politiker den Wählern geben der wahre
Grund ist dass es sehr große Banken und
maklerfmen gibt die es nicht mögen wenn
kleine Firmen wie meine mit ihnen
konkurrieren deshalb wollen sie uns mit
bürokratischen Hörden behindern sie
können es sich leisten für die
Vorschriften zu bezahlen kleine Firmen K
könen das nicht sie haben es nicht getan
um den Anlegern zu helfen sondern um den
großen Maklerfirmen zu helfen die sich
vor der Konkurrenz schützen wollen die
Drehtür ist dass wenn diese Leute
Washington verlassen Sie bequeme Jobs
bei den Firmen bekommen die sie früher
reguliert
haben sie wechseln von der Industrie zur
Regierung zurück zur Industrie und zur
Regierung was sie tun ist dass sie mit
ihrem Einfluss hausieren
gehen sie gehen nach Washington um
Einfluss zu gewinnen um sich Freunde zu
machen und dann verkaufen sie ihren
Einfluss an den Meistbietenden wenn sie
wieder
gehen traurigerweise ist die
Finanzindustrie vielleicht das beste
Beispiel für die Verflechtung von
Regierung und
Großunternehmen so wurde z.B berichtet
dass der Finanzminister Jacob blue von
seinem früheren Arbeitgeber der City
Group einen Bonus von 950 000 bekam nur
weil er einen Job im Finanzministerium
annahm
während seiner Zeit als Betriebsleiter
bei der City Group beaufsichtigte Jacob
blue den hgef der auf den Zusammenbruch
des Immobilienmarktes wettete die City
Group die drittgrößte Bank in den USA
erhielt 2008 45 Milliarden Dollar an
[Musik]
rettungsgeldern wenn Sie den Beweis für
den Faschismus sehen wollen brauchen Sie
nur vier einfache Worte zu lesen zu groß
zum Scheitern die Verschmelzung von
staatlicher und unternehmerischer macht
als Amerika 2008 eine Finanzkrise hatte
änderte sich das ganze
[Musik]
Spiel die Banken gerieten in
Schwierigkeiten sie holten Henry Paulson
den US Finanzminister und ehemaligen
Vorstandsvorsitzenden von Goldman Sax
und der sagt wir müssen die Banken
retten sie sind zu groß um zu scheitern
im November 2007 ernannte Präsident Bush
Neil kashkari zum stellvertretenden
Finanzminister für internationale
Wirtschaft und Entwicklung qashkari
verfasste und beaufsichtigte das
troubled asset Relief program das die
Rettung der Wall Street ermöglichte
kashkari auch der Bailout zah genannt
war investment banker bei Goldman
[Musik]
Sax
die subprime Hypothekenkrise von 2008
war der größte wirtschaftliche
Zusammenbruch seit der Großen Depression
mitten in der Krise forderten die
Finanzmedien strengere Vorschriften für
die
Finanzindustrie der
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Peter Schiff
der die Krise jahrelang vorausgesagt hat
ist der Meinung dass nicht nur die wall
Schu trägt sondern dass vor allem die
Regulierungsbehörden die mit der
Finanzindustrie zusammenarbeiten für die
Krise verantwortlich
[Musik]
sind die Regulierungsbehörden haben die
Krise verursacht es war die Regulierung
die das Problem geschaffen hat ich habe
2002 3 4 5 6 über die kommende
Immobilienkrise gesprochen und genau
aufgezeigt wie die Regierung und die
Zentralbank das Problem verursacht haben
die Leute die jetzt sagen wir hätten
nicht genug Regulierung wo waren die
damals warum haben sie 2004 und 5 nicht
gesagt dass wir mehr Regulierung
brauchen tatsache ist dass das Problem
durch die bestehenden Vorschriften
verursacht
wurde um die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln hat
die Zentralbank die Zinsen auf 1%
gesenkt das ermöglichte es den Leuten
sich billiger Geld zu leihen um Häuser
zu kaufen in der Zwischenzeit
garantierte die Regierung auch die
Hypotheken und das war das eigentliche
Problem die Art und Weise wie der Markt
die Banken reguliert besteht darin dass
die Menschen ihr Geld sicher aufbewahren
wollen und sich daher nach einem
sicheren Ort umsehen daher zwingt der
Druck des Marktes die Banken zu Vorsicht
um Einlagen anzuziehen sobald jedoch die
Regierung auf dem Plan tritt und sagt
dass Ihr Geld sicher ist egal was
passiert legt der Kunde keinen Wert mehr
auf Sicherheit weil die Regierung Sie
garantiert das Problem mit der
staatlichen Regulierung ist aber dass
sie ineffektiv ist und am Ende
politisiert wird denn wenn sie sich
daran erinnern dass während der Zeit des
Immobilienmarktes die
kreditvergabestandards immer weiter
gesenkt wurden war es die Regierung die
den Vorstoß zu Senkung der
standardsunternahmen weil die Wähler
mehr Häuser kaufen wollten weil der
Immobilienmarkt als eine Möglichkeit
angesehen wurde reich zu werden und das
einzige Hindernis war die Anzahlung die
Kreditwürdigkeit und so war es die
Regierung die Druck auf die Banken
ausübte hey vergesst die
Kreditwürdigkeit senkt die Anzahlungen
also kümmert sich niemand um irgendwas
weil die Regierung versucht alles gut zu
machen die Regierung sagt macht euch
keine Sorgen um das Risiko denn wenn ihr
scheitert sind wir da um euch
aufzufangen und wenn das nicht
funktioniert bekommt der Kapitalismus
einen schlechten Ruf als ob das alles
irgendwas mit Kapitalismus zu tun
hätte wenn wir ins Jahr 2011 springen
finden wir die Geschichte von MF Global
einem
rohstoffmaklerunternehmen das vom
ehemaligen gverneur von New Jersey John
Corsin geleitet
wird für keine angenehme Rückkehr zum
capital Hill er wurde vorgeladen um den
Gesetzgebern mitzuteilen wie das von ihm
geleitete Unternehmen MF Global
zusammenbrach und was mit 1,2 Milliarden
Dollar an Kundengeldern geschah ich weiß
einfach nicht wo das Geld ist oder warum
die Konten bis heute nicht abgeglichen
wurden hassen sie es nicht auch wenn Sie
Ihre Schlüssel Ihr Telefon oder das Geld
anderer Leute in Höhe von einer
Milliarde Dollar nicht finden können das
ist so
frustrierend aber so unangenehm ist für
Corin auch gewesen sein mag dort zu
sitzen und so zu tun als ob er sich
schlecht fühlte so fühlten sich andere
von der Situation noch ein wenig mehr
angegriffen ich bin durch den MF Global
Skandal verbrannt worden John Corin der
ehemalige demokratische Governor von New
Jersey der ehemalige Senator von New
Jersey und der ehemalige Chef der
Goldman Sax
Bande nachdem er eine Zeit lang bei
wurde er der Chef von MF Global ja MF
perfekt MF Global griff auf mein Konto
zu und Stahl mein
Geld im sechsstelligen Bereich ich habe
hart für mein Geld gearbeitet ich habe
nicht an den Märkten spekuliert er hat
mein Geld
gestohlen als er untersuchte wie dieses
Geld von seinem Konto gestohlen wurde
ohne dass die Finanzaufsichtsbehörden
Eingriffen stieß er bei seinen
Nachforschungen auf das verräterische
Quietschen der
Drehtür die CFTC ist die Behörde die
Maklerfirmen wie MF Global
reguliert zum Zeitpunkt des MF raues
wurde die cfdc von einem gewissen Gary
Gensler geleitet einem engen Kollegen
von
Corin hat sein Team nicht ein einziges
Mal vergessen lassen worum es hier
eigentlich geht das amerikanische
Volk wissen Sie was die CFTC mit John
Corsin gemacht hat nachdem er mich und
Tausende von anderen beraubt hatte
nichts gar
nichts g Gansler war sein Lieutenant bei
Goldman Sax und er ist der Kopf der
CFTC sie wollen ich meine zu sagen dass
der Fuchs den Hühnerstall bewacht ist
dumm das
ist es ist noch
[Musik]
limmer der Zusammenbruch von MF Global
ist ein Beispiel für die Allianz
zwischen Aufsichtsbehörden und
Großunternehmen in der
Finanzbranche aber ein noch
beunruhigenderes Phänomen ein
sogenanntes wurde kürzlich in Zypern
beobachtet selbst bei meinen düstersten
Vorhersagen die ich im Laufe der Jahre
in diesem Parlament über das Verhalten
der eu-bosse gemacht habe hätte ich nie
gedacht dass sie in einer noch nie
daagewesenen Weise dazu übergehen würden
Geld von den Bankkonten der Bürger zu
stehen in Zypern haben die Banken
unverantwortlich gehandelt und die
Öffentlichkeit alleleger haben den Preis
dafür bezahlt sie nannten es einen
bailin um es anders klingen zu lassen
als einen
Bailout was passierte war dass viele der
Banken in Zypern eine Menge griechischer
Staatsanleihen kauften und die
griechischen Staatsanleihen sind in den
letzten Jahren fast zusammengebrochen
dadurch wurden diese zypriotischen
Banken fast zahlungsunfähig und sie
gingen wie immer zu Regierung und sagten
hey wir sind pleite könnt ihr uns helfen
und Geld für uns stehen und genau das
haben sie getan sie sagten einfach nimm
50% von allem über 100 000$ nimmt die
Hälfte von ihrem Geld nimmt es
einfach allein der Begriff bailin ist
eine Lüge das ist ein
Marketinginstrument um im Grunde einen
Diebstahl zu
vertuschen bei einem Bailout wird das
Geld aufgepeppt und den Banken gegeben
und die Öffentlichkeit zahlt
letztendlich dafür durch eine Steuer die
Inflation genannt wird weil es jetzt
mehr Geld gibt bei einem bailin
überspringt man den Teil der
Geldschöpfung und nimmt es einfach von
den Einlegern aber im Grunde gewinnen
die Banken in beiden Fällen auf Kosten
der
Allgemeinheit aber das war in Zypern
nicht in den USA die Bürger Nordamerikas
würden so etwas hinterhältiges wie einen
bailin auf keinen Fall
zulassen Kanada hat in seinen Haushalt
13 eine bailin Klausel aufgenommen die
besagt dass wenn die kanadischen Banken
Probleme haben sie das Geld einfach von
den Bürgern nehmen können die USA haben
ebenfalls darüber gesprochen die
Regierungen erlauben den Banken sowas zu
tun Zypern war das Modell um zu sehen ob
sie damit durchkommen sie sind damit
durchgekommen und jetzt hat es sich als
erfolgreich erwiesen sass es eine Lösung
ist die Sie in Zukunft nutzen
können Nachhinein scheint es
offensichtlich dass der Finanzsektor
voller Korruption und Bestechung ist das
Finanzwesen das Bildungswesen das
Gefängnissystem der militärisch
industrielle Komplex fast jede Branche
in der es Geld zu verdienen gibt ist von
der Drehtür
betroffen sogar relativ neue Agenturen
sind von den Machenschaften betroffen
wenn Sie einen Beweis brauchen nehmen
Sie einen Nagelknipser mit auf einen
Inlandsflug
wenn Sie zum Flughafen gehen wollen die
Agenten der transportsicherheitsbehörde
TSA in ihre Privatsphäre eindringen ihre
Taschen durchsuchen und du hast nicht
die Möglichkeit Nein zu sagen wenn du
einmal in der Schlange stehst kommst du
nicht mehr raus was ist der Sinn dieses
Systems es ist ein sicherheitstheater es
geht darum die Menschen zu verängstigen
nicht darum dass Sie sich sicher fühlen
denn je mehr man die Menschen
verängstigen kann desto mehr kann man
ihre Rechte einschränken und sie ständig
daran erinnern dass sie die Regierung
brauchen um für Ihre Sicherheit zu
sorgen die Körperscanner die Sie daran
hindern gefährliche Gegenstände wie
Wasserflaschen mit ins Flugzeug zu
nehmen wurden aufgrund von TSA
Vorschriften
installiert als Leiter des
Heimatschutzministeriums verlangte
Michael chdof dass alle Flughäfen des
Landes mit diesen Scannern ausgestattet
werden natürlich zu unserer
Sicherheit mit dieser Technologie können
wir jeden am Körper verborgenen
Gegenstand aufspüren auch unter der
Kleidung verstecktes
Plastik die Scanner selbst werden von
einer Firma namens rapiscan gebaut und
installiert können Sie erraten wer nach
seinem Ausscheiden aus dem Heimatschutz
als Berater für rapiscan gearbeitet hat
oh ja ich erinnere mich lassen Sie mich
überlegen cherklov chkl cherkov
irgendein cherkov chk er war der Chef
der Homeland Security gleich nach dem
unterhosenbomber gleich danach erschien
cherklof ch KOF wie auch immer er heißt
in alle nationalen
Medien wir müssen die rönken Geräte da
reinbringen rapis
Scan Rapid Scan somebody Scan so heißt
die Firma sie wissen schon sie rönken
dich
oh so ein
Mist wow
cherclof wurde Berater für diese Firma
nachdem er die Homeland Security
verlassen
hat okay lassen Sie uns das klarstellen
Gentechnik sicher Rohmilch unsicher
Geflügel im Freien zuzubereiten ist
unhygienisch aber Medikamente die
Herzinfarkte verursachen sind okay wenn
man einen Joint raucht will man töten am
Flughafen geröncht zu werden ist für die
nationale Sicherheit unerlässlich und
seine Kunden zu bestellen ist okay
solange man es mit einer Milliarde
Dollar auf einmal
tut da die Regulierungsbehörden so eng
mit dem Großkapital verflochten sind ist
es fast unmöglich zu wissen ob die
Regeln nach denen wir leben zu unserer
Sicherheit oder zum finanziellen Vorteil
eines anderen erlassen wurden was auch
immer der Grund ist das Endergebnis ist
dass unser Leben jetzt so stark von den
Wünschen anderer manipuliert wird dass
unsere Wahlmöglichkeiten immer mehr
eingeschränkt
[Musik]
werden genau darum geht es bei der
staatlichen Regulierung unsere
Wahlmöglichkeiten einzuschränken die
Regierung will Entscheidungen für Sie
treffen Ihnen die Freiheit der Wahl
nehmen was sie essen all das wird von
der Regierung für sie bestimmt warum
können wir keine Entscheidungen treffen
darum geht es doch bei der Freiheit die
Politiker denken dass es wichtig ist
dass wir alle wählen dass Sie uns
vertrauen können aber sie trauen uns
nicht zu dass wir Entscheidungen darüber
treffen ob wir ein Haus kaufen oder
mieten welchen Makler wir nehmen ob ich
mich anschnalle oder einen Helm trage
oder ob ich Zigaretten rauche all diese
Entscheidungen müssen von der Regierung
getroffen werden irgendwie sind wir klug
genug um zu wählen aber wir sind zu dumm
um irgendetwas anderes zu
tun diese Überregulierung hat noch
andere Auswirkungen als nur die
Einschränkung unserer Wahlmöglichkeiten
dass die Behörden die Befugnis haben
unser Leben zu regulieren sogar im Namen
des Schutzes hat zu einer Ausweitung der
Regierungsmacht auf Kosten der
individuellen Freiheiten
geführt wie lautet das alte Sprichwort
gib ihnen einen Zentimeter und sie
werden dir dein Geld dein Leben und
deine lieblingsmilchprodukte wegnehmen
so in
etwa je mehr Gesetze es gibt je mehr
Vorschriften und Steuern desto weniger
Freiheit hat man das macht Freiheit aus
es ist die Freiheit von der Regierung
dann können die Menschen tun was sie
wollen sie müssen nicht tun was die
Regierung ihnen
sagt berufsbürokraten sind in der Regel
engagierte
regulierungsbefürworter sie sind Fans
von staatlicher Bevormundung von der
Regierung die individuelle
Entscheidungen trifft und das Ergebnis
ist dass der einzelne seiner
Souveränität beraubt wird es macht die
Menschen zu bloßen Funktionären des
Staates und nicht zu Menschen die ihren
eigenen Interessen nachgehen und die
Vorteile und Segnungen der Freiheit
genießen können
[Musik]
es läuft wirklich darauf hinaus wer mich
besetzt wem gehört das
Individuum man kann kein System haben
das uns die Wahlfreiheit verweigert
indem es versucht uns vor dem Risiko
einer schlechten Wahl zu schützen und
gleichzeitig die Freiheit bewahrt gute
Entscheidungen zu
treffen genau das ist das Problem man
kann nicht beides haben Freiheit
erfordert
Risiko sollte ich einen Gurt anlegen ist
diese Bank ein sicherer Ort für mein
Geld brauche ich eine
Versicherung wir sind alle so sehr mit
unserem täglichen Leben beschäftigt dass
wichtige Entscheidungen zu einer
überwältigenden Herausforderung werden
können viele Menschen ziehen es vor
keine Entscheidungen treffen zu müssen
auch wenn das bedeutet dass die
Entscheidungen die für Sie getroffen
werden nicht die besten
sind
viele Menschen ziehen es vor dass die
Regierung Entscheidungen für uns trifft
anstatt selbst welche zu
treffen aber wenn der Punkt erreicht ist
wie in der ehemaligen Sowjetunion an dem
der Staat so viele Entscheidungen für
einen trifft dass er die Wirtschaft
zerstört dass er den freien Handel
zerstört dass er jeden zum Diener und
den Staat zum Herrn macht dann kommen
die Menschen irgendwann in großer Zahl
zu dem Schluss dass sie nicht bekommen
was ihnen versprochen wurde dass sie
übermäßig besteuert werden dass sie
übermäßig reguliert werden dass ihre
Wahlmöglichkeiten eingeschränkt sind
dass die Bevormundung widerlich ist dass
sie mir Kummer bereitet hat und dass ich
sie ablehnen werde ich will meine
Freiheit bis dieser Punkt erreicht ist
werden die meisten Menschen mit ihrem
bequemen Leben und den ihnen noch zur
Verfügung stehenden
zufrieden
sein die hartarbeitenden Menschen haben
keine Zeit um zu sehen oder zu hören was
vor sich geht sie arbeiten rund um die
Uhr sie versuchen über die Runden zu
kommen wofür interessiert sich Amerika
also hey wissen Sie Kim Kardashian ist
schwanger und bekommt bald ein
Kind die Medien sorgen dafür dass wir
uns nicht seh einem wirklichsten
aufhalten wir alle kennen das Phänomen
das ein sehr ernstes Thema auftaucht
dass die ernsten Aspekte dessen was in
der Welt vor sich geht betrifft und das
für einen sehr kurzen Zeitraum in den
Nachrichten auftaucht und plötzlich wird
das abgeschaltet und wir werden mit
Seifenopern und Dancing with the stars
und allen möglichen Dingen abgelenkt die
unterhaltsam sind und ich sage nichts
gegen sie aber sie sind nicht so ernst
wie z.B die Beschneidung der Freiheit
durch einen neuen Zusatz zum Patriot
Act
die Medien mögen ihr Bestes tun um uns
eine faire und ausgewogene Meinung über
das Weltgeschehen zu vermitteln aber es
gibt jetzt andere Möglichkeiten für
diejenigen die ungefilterte Nachrichten
suchen das Netz ist sehr dezentral
aufgebaut die Macht liegt in den Händen
derjenigen die Nachrichten senden und
empfangen und nicht in den Händen derer
die sie weitergeben und das ist eine
beängstigende Aussicht für
altingesessene interesseng
[Musik]
alle alternativen Medien die nicht von
den Konzernmedien kontrolliert werden
sind eine
Bedrohung das Internet ist sicherlich
eine Bedrohung weil es fast jedem den
Zugang zur Welt
ermöglicht sind wir da überrascht wenn
die Politiker denen das nicht gefällt
sich ständig Gedanken darüber machen wie
wir das verhindern
können
nun die Formel hat sich bewährt sie
funktioniert immer man muss den Menschen
nur sagen dass es da draußen eine
Bedrohung gibt die nur die Regierung
kontrollieren
kann es gibt eine Bedrohung durch
Kinderpornografie oder Cyberterrorismus
oder sowas wir müssen das Internet für
sie kontrollieren sonst haben sie ein
großes
Problem deshalb arbeiten sie rund um die
Uhr daran den Menschen Angst einzujagen
damit sie denken dass das Internet von
unseren guten enswürigen Politikern
kontrolliert werden muss sie wollen
diejenigen sein die das Internet
kontrollieren und der Welt sagen was
richtig ist und was
falsch wenn man sich die Geschichte der
Kommunikationsmedien ansieht hieß es
immer das Kabelfernsehen befreit uns
endlich von der Zentralisierung das
Telegramm befreit
uns und das schlimmste Szenario wäre
wenn sich die Geschichte wiederholen
würde ichiche dezentralisierte
verteilungsmethode die effektivste die
jemals in der Geschichte der Menschheit
entwickelt wurde von einer Handvoll
zentralisierter Interessenvertreter
gekörpert werden würde und sie die
Kommunikation kontrollieren und
überwachen
[Musik]
würden gute Dinge sind anders als
Schmelzkäse nie von Dauer in dem
betreiben einen weiteren Teil unseres
Lebens zu regulieren sind bereits
Gesetzesentwürfe in Arbeit die versuchen
das Internet zu kontrollieren aber
anstatt auf lästige Bürokratie wie die
Verabschiedung von Gesetzen zu warten
hat die Regierung proaktiv versucht das
Internet zu zensieren natürlich zu
unserer Sicherheit mit Hilfe ihrer guten
Freunde aus der Finanzwelt wäre es ihnen
z.B fast gelungen die umstrittene
Webseite Wikileaks zu
schließen man kann über Wikileaks denken
was man will der Punkt ist dass
Mitglieder der Regierung in der Lage
waren einfach mit Zahlungsdienstleistern
zu sprechen und diese Blockade zu
errichten und zu sagen sie können kein
Geld an dieser Organisation überweisen
und es ist kein großer Sprung zu sagen
moment mal die Regierung oder in manchen
Fällen unternehmen können entscheiden
dass niemand mit diesen Leuten Geschäfte
machen kann oder dass niemand sehen kann
was diese Leute veröffentlichen das ist
offensichtlich ein Problem in unserer
Tradition der freien
Meinungsäußerung Wikileaks konnte
überleben vor allem dank eines sehr
neuen
dezentralisiertes
Geld im Gegensatz zu den meisten
Währungen der Welt die von den
Zentralbanken geschaffen und reguliert
werden wird dezentralisiertes Geld wie
Bitcoin von den Menschen geschaffen und
es daher fast unmöglich zu
kontrollieren bitcoin ist eine
dezentralisierte Peer topeer Währung es
ist eigentlich ein Internetprotokoll so
ähnlich wie SMTP mit dem man E-Mails
verschickt nun es ist Geld über das
Internetprotokoll so können wir Geld
über das Internet verschicken und wir
können es nutzen um Werte ohne einen
Mittelsmann zu übertragen das heißt wir
brauchen keine Bank oder einen
geldübermittler wie Western Union wir
können einfach Geld senden wie wir eine
E-Mail
senden Bitcoin ich bin unglaublich
begeistert davon weil es das erste
private Geld des freien Marktes ist
technologisches Geld eine elektronische
Währung das tolle dar ist dass es nicht
von einer Zentralbank kontrolliert wird
es ist das Geld des Volkes und es gibt
uns eine Menge
Freiheit warum werden die Geldmenge und
die Kosten des Geldes oder die Zinssätze
von einigen Bürokraten 3000 Meilen
entfernt in Washington DC
festgelegt wie effizient ist das für
unsere Wirtschaft denn die Zinssätze
regulieren die Produktion innerhalb der
Wirtschaft ob wir sparen oder etwas
bauen sollen
Bitcoin befreit diesen Zinssatz weil es
eine zensurresistente Währung ist so
dass wir ihr Geldsystem nicht mehr
benutzen
msen dezentralisierte Währungen wie
Bitcoin bieten eine Alternative zu den
stark regulierten nationalen Währungen
der Welt aber wie bei dem Vorstoß der
Regierung das Internet zu regulieren hat
es auch schon Versuche gegeben den Kauf
von Bitcoin zu regulieren
ich habe kürzlich versucht einen Bitcoin
Automaten zu gründen ich habe einige
Anwälte angeheuert und sie sagten mir
dass man in den USA unter fünf
verschiedene Regulierungsbehörden fällt
Bankwesen Finanzwesen Geldwesen sogar
Telekommunikation weil wir das Internet
nutzen wir haben uns die Gesamtkosten
angeschaut nur um einen einfachen
Bitcoin Geldautomaten zu starten nicht
weniger als 25 Millionen Dollar weil wir
alle möglichen versicherungsgarantien
brauchen auf diese Weise halten Sie die
Konkurrenz fern weil sie keine
Konkurrenz
wollen diese versuche immer mehr
Bereiche unseres persönlichen Lebens zu
kontrollieren beunruhigen einige Leute
sehr und mit jedem neuen Gesetz oder
jeder neuen Verordnung wird die
Versuchung immer größer ganz
auszusteigen es gibt einige Leute die
das Schiff verlassen sie sehen dass es
sinkt und Sie wissen nicht ob es
untergehen wird oder sich irgendwie über
Wasser halten kann sie wollen nicht in
der Nähe bleiben um das herauszufinden
ich werde niemandem s dass er nicht
gehen soll weil ich nicht genau weiß wie
schlimm es werden
kann Jeff Berwick hat sich bereits für
den Ausstieg
entschieden er hat eine
expertgemeinschaft in Chile gegründet um
einen Zufluchtsort für freiheitsliebende
Menschen zu schaffen die die Einmischung
der Regierung in ihre persönlichen
Angelegenheiten nicht länger hinnehmen
wollen wir haben diese Gemeinschaft
gegründet weil wir erkannt haben dass
viele Menschen aus diesen westlichen ler
wegen steigende Steuern zunehmende
Regulierung Menschen werden in den USA
ständig für nichts in den Knast gesteckt
für Verbrechen ohne Opfer die Leute
haben nichts getan außer vielleicht
Rohmilch zu trinken oder ein paar
Pflanzen namens Marihuana in der Tasche
zu haben den wir hier anziehen wollen
das sind freiheitsliebende
Menschen jeder hat seine ganz
persönliche Geschichte der eine wurde in
einem Monat zehn Mal angehalten und
durchsucht dem anderen wurde durch
Regulierung und Faschismus ein gesamtes
Geschäft
weggenommen kürzlich kam ein Arzt her
der eine Praxis in den USA hatte er
hatte eine fast hundertprozentige
Heilungsrate bei
Krebs und eines Tages kamen 30 SWAT
teams und nahmen alles mit so viele
Leute haben einfach genug davon
herumgeschupst bestohlen geschlagen und
umsonst in Käfige gesteckt zu werden
dass ihnen der Großteil ihres Geldes und
manchmal sogar ihre ganze
Existenzgrundlage genommen
wird
[Musik]
nicht jeder von uns kann einfach sein
Leben einpacken und nach Chile ziehen
welche praktischen Möglichkeiten gibt es
also noch ein guter Ansatzpunkt ist es
die Wurzel des Problems zu
identifizieren das Problem ist dass es
eine Verschmelzung von Privatwirtschaft
und Regierung gibt und die einzige
Möglichkeit diese zu durchbrechen
besteht darin die Macht des Staates zu
beschränken
wenn man dem Staat erst einmal die Macht
über unser Leben in all diesen Bereichen
gibt dann gibt es kein Halten
mehr denn dann werden die Leute die in
den Bereichen Medizin Geld Banken Strom
Gas und Öl all diese Dienstleistungen
anbieten zur Regierung gehen Politiker
kaufen die Gesetze in Ihrem Interesse
verabschieden und die durchschnittliche
Kaugummi kauende Öffentlichkeit denkt oh
das ist nicht nett nun wir haben für
diese Leute gestimmt also ist es wohl
unserem besten Interesse sie verstehen
es nicht wenn man den politischen Ämtern
die ganze Verlockung die ganze Macht
nimmt dann werden die einzigen Leute die
sich darauf einlassen diejenigen sein
die ihrem Land dienen wollen weil es
keine Möglichkeit mehr gibt etwas zu
stehen die einzige Idee die ich habe um
die Regierung zu verkleinern ist in den
Vereinigten Staaten haben wir eine
Verfassung aber jede Regierung könnte
eine Art von Verfassung zZ oder was auch
immer verabschieden der besagt dass Sie
für jedes Gesetz oder jede Verordnung
die diese Spinner verabschieden wollen
zwei alte Gesetze Akten oder
Verordnungen finden müssen die sie
aufheben müssen das ist der einzige Weg
den ich mir vorstellen kann um die
Regierung kleiner zu machen und das
gleiche gilt für alle Behörden wenn Sie
eine andere Behörde oder Abteilung
eröffnen wollen müssen sie zwei
schließen freheit ist das was die
Menschheit ausmacht Gesetze und
Vorschriften können uns zwar das Gefühl
geben vor Bedrohungen sicher zu sein
aber alle Sicherheit der Welt bedeutet
nichts ohne die Freiheit so zu leben wie
man
will die Freiheit ist die wichtigste und
unverzichtbare Eigenschaft des
Menschen wir können durch Versprechungen
der Regierung dazu gebracht werden von
unserer Freiheit abzuweichen aber es
gibt nichts Schlimmeres für den
Einzelnen als wenn ihm etwas verweigert
wird dass er dringend braucht weil er
sich zuvor entschieden hat auf seine
Freiheit zu
verzichten wenn sie unhallbar krank sind
und plötzlich feststellen dass sie nur
Zugang zu zugelassenen Behandlungen für
ihre Krankheit haben und ihnen von den
behandelnden Ärzten gesagt wird dass es
kein Medikament zur Behandlung ihrer
Krankheit
gibt um zu überleben müssen Sie also
etwas anderes
finden und sie stellen fest dass ihr
Wunsch und ihre Entscheidungsfähigkeit
dieses Ziel zu erreichen von der
Arzneimittelbehörde blockiert wird wenn
Sie also Ihre Freiheit am meisten
brauchen wird sie ihnen
genommen wenn sie zu einer Familie
gehören die seit 300 Jahren oder mehr
eine Milchfarm hat und plötzlich kommen
Bundesbeamte und führen eine Razia auf
ihrer Farm durch als wären sie ein
Drogenboss der in internationale
Drogengeschäfte verwickelt ist
und sie verkaufen nur Milch dann merken
sie dass ihr ganzes Leben auf den Kopf
gestellt wurde oder sie sind ein
Kleinunternehmer der feststellt dass sie
für den Betrieb einer Tankstelle
Vorschriften einhalten müssen die sie
mehr kosten als sie mit der Tankstelle
verdienen oder sie wollen einen
Lebensmittelbetrieb ein Restaurant
betreiben und sie entdecken dass die
staatlichen und lokalen Vorschriften so
umfangreich sind dass sie Anwälte
Buchhalter und speziell für die
Einhaltung der Vorschriften geschulte
Personen
brauchen und Sie müssen all diese
Formulare ausfüllen und Sie müssen all
diese Gebühren zahlen und sie brauchen
separate Lizenzen nur um Lebensmittel
weiter zu verkaufen die andere bereits
hergestellt und auf den Markt gebracht
haben das ist das Ende der
Freiheit
wie man die Freiheit zurückgewinnt ist
eine große
Frage der einzelne weiß dass er oder sie
am Leben
ist der einzelne weiß dass er frei ist
eine Zukunft und ein Leben zu
wählen das er
will
entweder wir haben freie Gesellschaften
oder wir haben keine entweder gibt es so
etwas wie individuelle Freiheit oder es
gibt sie nicht das ist die
Quintessenz wenn man ein Leben ein
richtiges Leben führen
will dann muss es Freiheit
geben deshalb müssen die Menschen aktiv
werden wenn sie die individuelle
Freiheit in irgendeinem Bereich
menschlicher Aktivitäten bedroht
sehen das ist der
Ausgangspunkt als ich aufwuchs war New
York eine hässliche Stadt in der es viel
Gewalt gab und die Leute räumten auf
indem Sie auf die Straße gingen und
sagten nie wieder das hat funktioniert
um die Banden zu stoppen das gleiche
funktioniert wenn man ehrliche Leute
findet die sich in der Regierung
engagieren und vielleicht können wir
dann die regierungsbanden davon abhalten
die Bedingungen unseres Lebens zu
diktieren und uns daran zu die Freiheit
zu haben die uns garantiert wurde in
einer offenen
Demokratie wir sind alle Individuen wir
haben die Fähigkeit zu denken zu
entscheiden und vor allem gehört zu
[Musik]
werden es ist vielleicht an der Zeit
über verschüttete Milch zu
weinen
mist ich habe es verschüttet das ist
nicht
gut junge ich habe gerade die Bilder der
schwangerin Kim Kardashian gesehen Mann
wie kann eine Frau wie sie warum wollen
sich das alle
ansehen sie ist ein
Star
also ihr wollt ihn nicht drin
haben okay geh
daunter nein ich weiß nicht wo man Gras
her kriegt
das ist gelogen das ist eine
unverfrorene Lüge nein ich ma nur
[Musik]
Witze